Transcription: Almudena Torrecilla
Relecteur: eric vautier
Oser, qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Eh bien, c’est ce que je suis
en train de faire maintenant.
Et puis je peux vous dire
que ce n’est pas facile.
Au début, je n’ose pas.
Et puis quand mon mari a réussi
à me convaincre, je me lance.
Et dans ce sens, je suis un peu comme
le baril de poudre et il est l’étincelle.
Et il est venu comme ça, une fois,
avec une idée, un super projet.
Il m’a dit :
« J’aimerais que tu deviennes
la première paracycliste
à réaliser le raid pyrénéen. »
C’est quoi, le raid pyrénéen ?
La traversée des Pyrénées,
de l’Atlantique à la Méditerranée.
800 kilomètres, 18 000 mètres
de dénivelé positif en dix jours,
et à la force des bras, bien sûr.
Ce projet m’enthousiasmait.
Vraiment je trouvais que c’était génial,
mais en même temps,
j’avais des appréhensions,
j'avais des craintes.
Je pensais déjà
aux côtés de l’organisation,
comment faire mes traitements
pour le handicap durant un tel périple ?
Et puis je pensais aussi
aux inflammations,
aux blessures
que cela pourrait occasionner.
Parce que, à ce moment-là,
j’étais encore en plein
dans ma carrière sportive de handbike.
J’avais des comptes à rendre
à mes sponsors, à ma fédération sportive
qui s’attendaient aux résultats
auxquels je les avais habitués.
Mais j'ai vaincu ces appréhensions.
Je l'ai fait et j'ai réussi.
Et c'est vrai que c'était extraordinaire.
J’ai pu être la première paracycliste
à réaliser ce défi,
ouvrir une voie
et même faire encore
une étape du Giro d’Italie après,
que j’ai pu gagner.
Et tout ça,
ça m’a donné l’énergie
et ça m’a montré
que finalement, en y allant,
eh bien,
on découvre qu’on a des forces en soi
qui sont insoupçonnées.
Et finalement on peut
se poser la question :
c’est quoi oser ?
Oser, est-ce que c’est...
de la rébellion ?
Est-ce que c’est de l’audace ?
Est-ce que c’est du courage ?
Audiard disait :
« Il vaut mieux parfois se taire
et passer pour un con
que de parler et de ne laisser
aucun doute à ce sujet. »
Eh bien,
ce soir, je prends ce risque.
Je pense qu’oser demande
une certaine forme de courage,
parce que
l’échec est envisageable.
A la base, je n’ai pas du tout
de facilité à parler en public,
mais j’ai appris, je me suis formée,
je me suis laissé conseiller.
D’ailleurs, enfant, j’étais très timide
et je m’épanouissais à travers
la gymnastique, la danse, l’acrobatie.
J’en ai même fait mon métier
en devenant trapéziste et contorsionniste.
Après quinze ans
dans ce magnifique métier,
j’ai chuté du trapèze
et je me suis retrouvée
telle que vous me voyez maintenant :
paraplégique.
Et à ce moment-là,
j’avais tout perdu,
mon identité, le travail de ma vie.
Et j’ai eu cette image
d’un château de sable.
Je ressentais mon corps
comme un château de sable.
Tous mes accomplissements qui ont pu
être balayés par une grosse vague,
par une intempérie.
Tout au long de notre vie,
nous prenons des rôles.
Tantôt nous sommes parents, sportifs,
artistes, hommes d'affaires.
Et tout ça, c’est un peu
comme des châteaux de sable.
Quand j’étais artiste,
je disais bien : « Je suis artiste »,
comme nous avons tous
l’habitude de le faire.
Je disais « je suis », mais en fait,
ce n’était qu’un rôle
que je prenais le temps
d’un épisode de ma vie.
Mais, qui sommes-nous lorsque nous perdons
notre couple, notre travail,
notre vie ?
Quand tout cela ressemble
à ce château de sable
qui se fait engloutir
par une grosse vague.
Après l’accident,
des amis m’avaient dit : « Il faudrait
que tu fasses du sport de haut niveau. »
Mais je n’osais pas réinvestir
dans quelque chose qui était
autant axé sur le corps physique
que je ressentais comme si vulnérable,
si délicat, si fragile.
Comme ce château de sable
qui aurait pu de nouveau s’écrouler.
Jusqu’à ce que je prenne conscience
que finalement ce n’est pas le but,
l’objectif qui était important,
mais tous les souvenirs,
les enseignements, les émotions
que nous gagnons au cours du chemin.
Et puis finalement,
qu’il existe des fondements.
Mais les fondements ne sont pas là
où je pensais au début,
dans les murs solides
de nos accomplissements.
Les fondements sont dans quelque
chose de bien plus subtil.
Dans notre intérieur, dans notre cœur,
dans nos pensées.
Et ces fondements.
c’est ce qui m’est resté après l’accident.
J’avais tout perdu,
j’avais perdu mes relations,
j’avais perdu le travail d’une vie,
j’avais perdu mon corps
tel que je le connaissais.
Mais il me restait à l’intérieur de moi
de la volonté, de la détermination,
de la discipline personnelle.
Et c’est ça que j’ai pris,
ces fondements solides, subtils, en moi,
pour reconstruire, pour reconstruire
de nouveaux châteaux de sable.
Parce que je savais, je n’avais plus peur.
Je me disais que même
si ça devait échouer,
j’avais cette force en moi
pour rebondir, pour recommencer.
Et c’est ainsi
que je me suis lancée
dans une carrière de handbike
pendant dix ans.
J’ai fait de nombreuses compétitions.
C’est ainsi que j’ai entamé
cette collaboration avec l’EPFL
pour le développement
de l’exosquelette Twiice
qui au début n’était pas du tout
ce à quoi il ressemble maintenant.
Et c'était très difficile.
Il fallait tout mettre en place.
Mais vous savez,
au début,
quand je me mettais
à un départ de course de handbike,
j’avais toujours peur.
J’avais peur d’un nouvel accident,
j’avais peur d’un carambolage,
j’avais peur de me renverser
dans les virages.
Parce que dans les courses,
les athlètes sont
très agressifs et imprévisibles,
parce que tout le monde veut gagner.
Mais j'ai surmonté ces peurs.
Je l'ai fait.
Et avec l'exosquelette aussi.
Au début, où il n’était pas encore
aussi développé que maintenant,
j’avais peur de perdre
le contrôle de la machine.
J'avais peur de foncer dans un obstacle.
J'avais peur de tomber.
Mais j’ai poursuivi, j’ai continué.
Et
si je n’avais pas été
au départ de ces courses,
si je n’avais pas surmonté cette peur,
je n’aurais jamais pu vivre toutes
ces émotions sportives extraordinaires,
je n’aurais jamais pu gagner toutes
ces médailles, ces records du monde,
ces médailles au niveau international.
Si je n’avais pas persévéré
avec ces entraînements de l’exosquelette
qui étaient vraiment difficiles au début,
nous n’aurions jamais pu amener cet
appareil à l’état où il est aujourd’hui
et apporter une indépendance
et une liberté de mouvement
à toutes les personnes
qui sont en mobilité réduite.
Et dans cette même continuité,
si je n’avais pas
ouvert cette porte de la peur
pour aller chercher
ce qui se cachait derrière,
je n’aurais jamais pu recevoir
le plus beau cadeau de ma vie,
qui a été ce retour...
à ma...
première passion, à mes premiers amours,
ce retour à mon métier
d’artiste de cirque.
J’ai pu inventer,
treize ans après l’accident,
une technique qui me permet de bloquer
les parties paralysées de mon corps.
Et ainsi me mettre en équilibre
sur les mains.
J’ai recréé un spectacle, un numéro.
Et vous n’imaginez pas.
La première fois
que je suis retournée sur scène,
mon corps tremblait,
mon cœur battait la chamade.
C’était affreux le trac que j’avais -
d’ailleurs, que j’ai toujours -
(Rit nerveusement)
Mais -
Oui, merci,
(Applaudissements)
Mais je l'ai fait et j'avais peur.
J’avais peur de la réaction du public
parce que, aller sur scène
avec un handicap,
je ne savais pas
comment ça allait être reçu.
Je ne savais pas si j’allais réussir
à réaliser la performance
telle que je l’avais entraînée.
Je ne savais pas si j’allais réussir
à transmettre ce message d’espoir,
de force intérieure que j’avais envie
de transmettre à travers mes gestes.
Et puis, je crois que
les applaudissements du public
ont été pour moi
cette lumière qui se cache
derrière cette porte de la peur
que vous pouvez ouvrir
si vous faites un pas,
si vous osez faire le pas,
le premier pas, et le suivant.
Je vais vous montrer à quoi ça ressemble
pour que mes mots et des images....
(Musique)
Eh bien, ce soir, j’ai envie de vous dire
vous aussi, vous pouvez créer,
créer des œuvres,
créer des châteaux de sable,
même s’ils sont voués à disparaître.
Ne vous laissez pas arrêter
et bloquer par cette peur
parce que vous savez
que les fondements, ils sont en vous.
Que, en vous, il y a cette force.
Cette force qui vous permet
de vous relever quoi qu’il arrive.
Si un château se fait ébranler,
vous en aurez récolté
des accomplissements.
Et
j’ai envie de vous dire,
là, ce soir,
moi, assise sur mon trône,
je préfère être la reine des connes
que d’être un mouton
dont la tête ne dépasse pas du troupeau.
Alors,
sortez du troupeau et rejoignez-moi.
(Applaudissements)